l'exemple que j'entends qui est très
frappant puisque le connais assez bien
elle est en berne y est plutôt d'avoir
le kamouraska témiscouata dans ce que je
disais tout à l'heure
montmagny l'islet kamouraska l'a proposé
elzéar bernier mondiale bernie et
peut-être pas connu tellement tellement
il a un budget provincial et c'est un
grand navigateur c'était qui a fait sa
marque nord canadien existants presse
n'existe pas à cause des abers
d'ailleurs vers nîmes il est connu à
partir d'alger à bernier et les
missionnaires oblats 20 mai à 10h
dernière quand celui qui a contribué le
plus à la connaissance du grand nord et
qui amène le premier ministre actuel
pour mon sens les gars allaient faire
son tour annuel dont les géants bernier
la réaction a été mon connaître au chaud
ce qui sort alors ça a été les gens il
ya eu un refus lé refus dit ignorer en
quelque sort mais on voulait pas aller
plus loin